um
oh hi there scallywag
care to come aboard
up for a cruise around the bay kicking
in with old carrie
okay yeah sounds promising i'm in
music to my [ __ ] ears off we go
now if i can find that button to raise
him
dad samurai
all ahead
[Music]
two
okay so let me hear what this is all
about
like i said life's loops
uh breakfast cereal no no no no
loops cycles
one chapter ends another begins
life's full of them at least my guru
tells me so
[Music]
i'll bite tell me about these loops
okay so first tune i ever wrote
that was worth a damn
and you notice fingers are on to
something fresh again today
there's a loop for you
and you need company for that
not just your company i needed you
me
i've been thinking about that those
cracks yet
let's go lately about how you help me
you shake things up babe make me feel
i i mean before you came along i was
stuck in the mud
i'm scared of my own shadow even and now
had what i think folks call an epiphany
could just be what folks call maturity
you'll see no more mayhem no more shady
ass schemes
done with that
well starting tomorrow
he's
all right now for a breath of freedom
[Music]
you gonna [ __ ] help me i just stand
there like a god
chaos and destruction why the [ __ ] not
grab something heavy and no regrets
after
owning a trash yacht my yacht
honestly think i'd name my boat samurai
[ __ ] who's the [ __ ] is it redhead
[ __ ]
lb cover check
kovachick
do something and smash it this one's on
lb
okay let's rip this boat to shreds
well well finally ready to party
either he's gone senile or he's finally
wise in the [ __ ] up
could be either
[Music]
300
give me a hand with this [ __ ]
no thanks me i'm all right
still got a little left in you remember
when you woke up in that scrap yard
that's where he is now being reborn with
[ __ ] all the stopping
it's time for the grand finale do the
honors be
ah baptism by fire and wire
eight [ __ ] men
[Music]
settling scores well [ __ ] sick
suck on this cover check
race to the beach
so
i think i ought to start using my own
pool more often
come here kid
just hold your breath a little ways
wreak something real what if it don't
blow
take that back
we'll come with black market c6 what do
you think
never mind
gotta admit not bad it was [ __ ] wild
to settle that score
to mark a new beginning
thanks fee ah hell in the night huh
felt like samurai's first few gigs
the energy was [ __ ] raw nice twist of
events
i gotta admit all right
let's get out of here before the wind
flips and you get flooded by that stench
need a ride of course i do
come on man
[Music]
hey v haven't heard of any cyber psycho
attacks lately
i think it's time we put an end to our
little arrangement
drop